[Music]
what has been one of the best birthday
gifts 30 years ago is now a terrible
surprise in the 21st century stay tuned
until the end to know which toy was
dangerously fun if you love toys as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 20 toys from
the 80s no kid would want to receive
today view-master in the 80s looking
through these toys felt like you were
looking at another world in that moment
you were the only one who could look at
these secret pictures some of them were
even in 3d however this toy has nothing
that could ever impress a kid nowadays
they might be curious enough to look at
all the pictures once but that's all
there is no way a kid is going to play
with this for more than 5 minutes in the
21st century now that we have cell
phones and the whole universe to
discover online the viewmaster looks
like something that was created by
dinosaurs troll dolls no matter when we
were born we all had troll dolls and
these toys were more popular than ever
in the 80s their popularity could only
be explained by the fact that they were
strangely cute and had funny hair or
maybe a little bit of magic was all it
took for kids all around the world to
want one they were known as good luck
trolls though he never became
millionaires so they probably didn't
work and we all had at least one troll
doll and this is why we can all agree on
one thing we never understood what we
were supposed to do with this we all
ended up cutting their hair and
regretting it that's a sketch this toy
was one of the coolest things ever
created when we were kids
this red tablet gave us the chance to
create cool drawings and become the
artists of the future actually that's
only what the commercials made us
believe because no kid ever found a way
to create something nice with this then
the etch-a-sketch gave us even more
opportunities to simply fail at becoming
artists that's because we could only
aspire to create something that was
fairly recognizable and making something
cool was pretty much impossible kids
nowadays can do something better on a
free website and something even greater
has existed for a couple of centuries a
pen and a piece of paper Garbage Pail
Kids cards we all remember the Pokemon
cards and it feels like this toy will
never get old but another
Toye was even more popular in the 80s
and that was the Garbage Pail Kids cards
the only reason why we wanted this was
that the cool kids at school had this
and when we think that they once made us
think that Crocs look good we now know
that these cool kids could make us do
anything and when we think about it
these cards were even more terrifying
than Crocs another thing that made them
better or worse was that they were
actually stickers that we could put
everywhere in our room and deeply regret
it one month after keepers if you had a
lot of Secrets but no friends you could
trust the keepers through the right toys
for you the adult keeper had a key and
unlocked a door somewhere on their body
and the baby keepers had a slit in their
backs this is how you could keep all
your little secrets inside them but we
think that our parents just bought these
toys because they wanted to open it and
see what we were hiding from them we
know that because that's what we did to
our little sister who had the same toys
kids nowadays have a better way to hide
their secret they share it with the
world on forums online Alf aliens did
invade our planet in the 80s
that's because Alf was everywhere at
that time we don't know how but we
managed to think that this weird
creature was kind of charming how can
you not like a nice toy that wants
nothing but cuddles and if you really
loved him you could even buy a talking
off that made you love your silent dolls
even more don't take it personally Alf
we love to tease the people that we love
the reason why we forget about this toy
could be that aliens erased our memory
or maybe they just weren't meant to last
for more than a decade fisher-price
cassette tape player kids love listening
to their own music and recording their
voice but if you ever tell them that
this is the only thing this toy can do
it will quickly end up in the trash can
what used to be really cool thirty years
ago is now so normal that we take it for
granted kids nowadays don't even
understand why we would listen to a
cassette when we can listen to thousands
of songs on an iPhone just as big as
this but don't make fun of kids of the
80s kids from 2030 will laugh out loud
when they see that we used to have
iPhones and
implants in our head light brights what
is this toy doing on this list we all
loved it when we were kids
life right gave us the opportunity to
create fun pictures with colored lights
we could use picture outlines or create
our own thing
to turn on the magic however we don't
think that kids will be impressed by
these huge pixels and now that they can
watch television in 4k but no matter
what we think that parents should give
it a try on their birthday and if they
don't like it grown-ups will be happy to
play with it go but you might be
surprised to hear that but go BOTS beat
the Transformers on the shelves in the
mid 80s
just like we recently saw in the popular
transformer movies these toy cars could
turn into robots however just because
they were so popular among parents
doesn't mean that they were more popular
among kids many of them were
disappointed when they received a gobots
instead of an Autobot and when
transformers became more popular weekly
forgot about these toys we guessed that
go BOTS should have made a movie if they
wanted to survive the gobots car might
go faster but Autobots always had more
endurance boggans even if you were born
in the 21st century you have probably
heard about the gremlins as most popular
toys came with a knockoff Bob Glenn's
had to be created these ugly creatures
came in a cage to better control them
but maybe some kids should have been
locked in a cage to to control
themselves from buying them that's
because these ugly creatures that came
alive in your hands were created for
nothing else but to disgust you however
we have to admit that they were a great
way to scare your little sister no
matter what these weird things will have
to stay in the past Speak & Spell we
spend enough time in school we don't
want to keep learning while we're
supposed to have fun Speak & Spell was
marketed as a tool to learn how to spell
and pronounce over 200 commonly
misspelled words you could even purchase
additional cartridges to play new games
new Speak & Spell models were also
created during the 80s but no matter
what every kid nowadays will say that
this is nothing compared to what a
smartphone
there are now tons of free apps that can
do the same thing or even more so
instead of buying a speaking cell you
should simply let the kids play on your
phone more often Teddy Ruxpin Teddy
Ruxpin was not a teddy bear like any
other there was a reason why he was our
best friend
this toy could speak this bear did have
a lot of potential at that time but its
creators turned it into something creepy
in the commercial you could see that
Teddy Ruxpin was coming to life just
like the Frankenstein monster it led
many kids to think that Teddy Ruxpin was
actually a living feature maybe he would
have had a better chance if the
commercial wasn't too scary for kids
after all children still love to play
with a speaking toy nowadays unless they
are old enough to speak to series the
power glove
this toy seemed awesome in theory but in
practice kids quickly realized it
couldn't turn them into superheroes
people thought that the power glove
would take their gaming experience to a
whole new level but unfortunately it was
impossible to do anything while wearing
this this is why it ended up being one
useless thing that parents bought and
the next generation already knew that
this game wasn't worth it there are so
much more things that we can do nowadays
to play video games that this toy
doesn't belong in the 21st century game
over power glove game over
Simon you all know this game and it was
more popular than ever in the 80s
Simon was showing you a series of
buttons to press and then you had to
repeat the same sequence again it got
harder and harder every time but no
matter what no one could beat Simon this
game is still popular nowadays but not
as much as it was before you might see
it once or two in a video game online
but that's it now that kids have iPhones
iPads and many other videogame consoles
there is no way they are going to be
interested in something so simple
Layton's we all love to build force with
pillows
blankets but in the 80s things had much
simpler when you could simply hide in
your play since that was a little room
for you and only you unless you shared
it with many other siblings but no
matter what we felt more responsible
when we had this little home for
ourselves however over the years kids
realize that they would rather keep
things simple why would they ask for a
play tent on their birthday when
building a blanket fort is funnier no
matter what we think that the plate in
to deserve a second chance
fisher-price rollerskates whether you
love or hate to roller-skate
you had to try this at least once in
your life and in the 80s it was easier
than ever to scratch your knee because
this thing was dangerous and you kept
falling just by taking one look at it
any kid nowadays would see that these
rollerskates are way too cheap to be
worn but that didn't stop kids from the
80s who wanted to act like grown-ups and
as wearing a helmet wasn't really
popular thirty years ago we think that
it probably led to a lot of injuries
come on just buy your kids some real
rollerskates and skip a trip to the
hospital
mad balls we don't know why but some
people thought that making this thing as
ugly as possible would make them better
if there was one good thing about the
mad balls it's that we could throw them
anywhere but then our brother threw one
in our face and we understood why they
were called mad balls do you think that
kids today will like it it can buy a
better looking ball at the dollar store
so we don't think that they would be
happy to receive on mad ball for their
birthday anyway we all know how this
story ends we all broke a window and
regretted it so much that we never
played with the ball again Popples
these toys weren't just cute stuffed
animals they could also turn into little
pillows and that's pretty much it
kids nowadays wouldn't be impressed even
though these little creatures were
really cute we would expect something a
little more special when someone says
that they are special kids who receive
something as simple as that might be a
little disappointed it could be a nice
toy to bring if you ever plan to go on a
trip as it doesn't take a lot of space
and it can be used as a pillow however
we don't recommend it for anyone's
birthday Nintendo in the 80s the first
Nintendo console was the best gift you
could ever wish for on Christmas we
did have to share it with our siblings
but it was totally worth it we had never
seen something so cool and this is why
it evolved into something incredible
nowadays however technology changes so
fast that kids are not interested in the
old Nintendo anymore
why would they play a game where they
can't really move or that they can't
take anywhere with them no matter what
it would be a great gift for a grown-up
who wants to play the games they used to
love in their childhood Pogo ball this
is the reason why kids shouldn't have
the right to watch commercials on TV the
Pogo ball looks incredibly dangerous but
no matter what all the kids wanted to
try it at least once it was pretty
simple the things got much more
complicated when kids ended up at the
hospital
with a lot of kids with fractured limbs
parents ended up confiscating their toys
and this is probably why they don't want
to buy them anymore but we still think
that this game was not that bad if you
could receive any of the toys on this
list which one would you like to have
don't be shy to answer in the comment
section down below and that's it 420
toys from the 80s no kid would want to
receive today if you liked this video
don't forget to subscribe and give us a
big thumbs up thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]